okay four people joining this livestream
we are continuing to look at database
functionality coming in at the 11th hour
for version 12 of orphaned language I am
unfortunately a bit under the weather I
have some random viral sickness and have
a fever here so I may be a bit subdued
and possibly more argumentative than
usual or possibly less argumentative I
don't know um all right let's get
started here
so we're starting with sample density
clasp
I thought we've gone through these what
did we not go through here
hello can you hear me what did we not go
through here ah
Carlota vanity has it we need to know
the answer of that because otherwise we
can't do this meeting any useful wife
where did the Letran I think from it's
from Andrea who's not working today so
yeah I think I think that the ones we
start to review means that you've gone
through most of the stuff so so what are
we doing here just tell me what we
should be doing otherwise no that's a DA
there are a bunch of there are a bunch
of symbols like for example entity
entity value what are you talking about
look you know updated symbols the
locator but this we haven't gone through
this is obviously not been processed by
me know this yeah you start looking at
this and then you said no it's figure
out what we're doing okay that's what I
want to know the answer to yeah that
looks like one that we've processed yeah
no this is obviously not something I
would have done here
okay so where are we starting we're
starting with combined entity class so I
go get an entry close to what you tell
me
probably combine this better because we
did part of it at least last okay but go
over it then by combining the public's
of those pairs of entities from class
one and class two
for which the value of the property prop
is the same
you
you
for the two entities
to say for the two entities in the pair
combines those advantages for which the
value of prop 1
okay
you didn't fix this we discussed that
there has to be fixed that subscript
right did that just get ignored
anybody no and it didn't have time to go
through all of that okay
well that something needs to be done
planning missing elements to be
generated okay fine
entity properties
you
is the join of the entity properties
from those two things right
why is it a special to argument for
magnet e function what's special about
it
that usually entity function is behaving
like property so it applies to an entity
in this case it applies to two entities
at the same time it's the only case
where it sells so in combined entity
class
of
plus one plus two s
the function f must be
the forum entity function
he missed a lobster on what I was a
funder function yes I must be of the
form entity function of e 1 comma E 2
dot-dot-dot
well
um II 1 and E to stand by the e I will
stand respectively
four and four entities in class one and
class two
you
okay any objections clicking sounds good
you
you know format running the formattings
system is about the level of what I'm
capable of doing in my
second state here today okay look
lighter okay cannot have two identical
okay this has got to be said better
you
okay so this is another form here right
um
oh you could always put an alias like
this couldn't you yeah yeah yeah sure so
yeah I think this is where we broke last
time like I was wondering whether that
should be its own research message
thinking
um
you know what I think we can do this um
I'm not sure how to do that usage
measures because either class could be
alias right yeah um so maybe you can
write something like in for instance in
in place of class these cells can be
used right right right right right um
what's that entity type name is class -
no that's not that's just whatever the
name of class - is
yeah okay hold on so um
you
uh in
you
in the result from combined entity class
properties
properties
and the result
from combined entity class
plus one plus two dot dot dot
of the form
and today property of type one
,
all of the neighbors
where
you
the type I are the entity types
of +1
Klaas I
you
okay combined
entity class
of quotes alias one arrow plus one
dot-dot-dot
can be used to
create
can be used to UM
give properties
of the form
entity property
you
of quotes alias I
arrow type I
you
you
humm
you
in
combined entity class
class 1 +2 the class I must be distinct
combined
enter the class of alias one
you
well okay
to this clasp
, quotes alias of clasp
can be used
four identical classes
maybe Steven we could done we could
stress that Alice's can also be used for
the second class because it's not
obvious for angry that you just
mentioned the first class Alice goes to
class one and then dot dot
maybe you should mention that
ress can be used also for the second
class
or do you think it's obvious I think
it's pretty obvious but but especially
given this example here can be used to
get properties of the form well okay
look here we can do this alias to
plus two
okay yeah
I'm telling you this is my calling
pressing option T which would be even
better if I was didn't have a
left-handed Mouse
you
okay
you
okay
okay this goes away
okay so now we want to say
in
you
um
the join specification
Jay speck
um
can have
same values as enjoin across
to wit
you
okay let's write this okay so that c1 c2
you
you
okay so now how do we write this out
you
what if what are the AI and BJ in this
case there are they are property
so okay so the problem is this is that
basically you are combining twenties and
in this case the AI the problem is that
in the association there is not really
the same direction so in this case what
we're doing is that means pack you have
mentions of some properties and if those
properties match then you you merge you
combine the entities that correspond to
those properties but yes but AI and BJ
are entities not properties hmm yes hey
I'm Jerry and in this case okay
keep only those entities so we
properties match or instead of
properties match who should say
something like entity function yields
true if yeah it's not the end
okay so that the issue is
the joint specification J spec
you
okay so it's determining when missing
will be generated right correct it's
gonna be the funk well though it's born
missing is that correct yeah about on
the other hand if you are doing inner
join it's not necessarily missing it's
just that some entity pairs will not be
picked okay fine
fine but if they are picked that either
are they missing okay to determine when
to allow entities containing missing
elements to be generated right that's
what it says they're missing properties
maybe it should say yeah okay with
missing properties to be generated
right mm-hmm okay so the joint
specification J spec
um
so what is it really doing it's working
like what it's it's the acer buys here
or what
so these are the about one o'clock - is
that correct yes
so to give an example imagine that
you're joining count trees with capital
cities the default is in there and so
you will get Rome Italy Paris France and
so on and so forth if okay so if you say
left and on the left are the countries
then it will be the same because all
countries are the capital but if it's
not right but the horrid or not okay if
you say right so then the difference in
that case is that if you do inner join
the new de team in the Western Sahara if
you right then you are gonna have all
the cities that we have in our entities
and for some of them they will not be
the capital of anything so they will
have a matched country yeah I understand
that okay
the joint specification
you
okay
all right hold on
okay
you
you
but we have that tea a was that come or
else
you
okay time thinking we do this
and
you
you
um the joint specification determines
okay hold on
determines
which of the entities
a sub I from Class C sub a
which entities a sub I from Class C sub
a and which entities
B sub I from Class B C sub D should be
cut
the possible specifications
of joint specifications
are the same as for join cross
you
you
you
I'm going to say for which properties
match and I'm going to say the
properties and I'm going to have a
separate note that says of the function
case okay
okay but what you could say is like
something like for which I mean because
the properties are including of a
condition so maybe we could say
something like which the condition is
true okay is Matt by which the condition
is met
you
should be kept
you can just write English F of a ibj is
it yields true but there's no F in most
of these cases is that well they're in
these you can't use that okay so let's
keep going because there's an implicit
equal in that case okay which entities
AI from class a and bi from Class B
should be kept um
depending on
look you know what let's do the matching
thing and then let's describe the
possible joint specifications
keep only those for which properties
match now what's this one
no bi with a matching property correct
correct it's not I might be correct in
some cases but but is it not correct
well sometimes the fact like the the
condition to decide whether to give a
separate that's a separate thing here
right I'm dealing with this case first
okay
I'm dealing with the case of properties
first also are you going to then expand
the same thing for more complicated case
or the I'm just gonna tell you that for
more complicated cases so maybe what we
could say why don't we just do this
but I mean I think that at least as far
as I remember for example I'll try to
explain this to Tony it's much clearer
if you first understand the general case
of that that is a condition because then
if you think about properties that it's
not clear that that it even make sense
to have inner outer when it's boolean
condition
okay well Tony speak up please
Tony
yes I'm just looking at the
implementation to get some inspiration
you
so I mean I would say something like
hold on hold on hold on this should take
cond I think for a condition know that
go ahead what we gonna say no what I was
gonna see is that instead of seeing for
which properties match you can see for
which the condition is met and then you
can see Wow wait wait wait wait wait
wait to the joy
specification determines which entities
AI from Class A and B Eiffel Class B
should be kept based on
you
whether the condition
defined by conned
is Matt
for each AI and BJ
you
so I'm saying
you
yeah but basically in the end what what
which should say is that when you do
left then you have if we can just say we
have all the entries in the Class A and
C okay okay well profiler maybe we want
a completely different table
why no no the table is fine that I'm
just saying is a inner keep only those
entities for which the the condition is
met and then left okay
keep only those AI for which the
condition is met yes and then for left
you see keep all the AI in Class A
I'll just say keep all the I that's it
right yeah keep all the i-ight
regardless of the BJ
yeah
maybe we should make a little drawing
here it's much easier if you look at
Venn diagrams well fine then then you
can do that that's a Rogerian tradition
I'm not gonna make the drawing you guys
should make this shirt before having it
all okay
you
okay now out so what's that one
keep all a I and BJ
you
right
just which doesn't mean cross-product
this is rather ponderously talking about
um
you
you
okay
okay fine okay why does this not refer
to any of the other combined aggregated
anything else
of functions
you onto that please I mean because it
didn't appear to me that there was one
that was more interesting than the
others but oh maybe it should refer to
what have we done with other ones here
what do we do I give you the same answer
I think now sorted has an obvious
relation to sampled because they will
mention it what doesn't this have an
obvious relationship to aggregated and
extended do you mean the company has an
obvious relation to aggregated combines
not really it's a completely orthogonal
operation well but you might have wanted
the aggregated operation instead but
they're different so with the same
vendor but that doesn't mean that if
they were the same we wouldn't be having
two separate functions for them Yeah
right but I mean if we list all these
operations there don't want to list all
of them we want somebody who might be
confused because they might say I want
to combine all entities of some type I
think we should list aggregate it
because I think it's a similar type of
idea whether we should and you know what
you know what's doing if we want to list
something whether it be extended because
both of them extend things but in a
slightly different way well in actually
different way so people may yeah all
right okay
okay have you started putting an example
fear
yeah I'm boy
you
now Ben on the livestream is expressing
the importance of examples and tutorials
which I thoroughly concur with
um
you know the example should really be
minimal why do you need three properties
here rather than just two
I don't know I inherited this example
but with modifications okay you know
what properties like this don't belong
in this and they know I mean the reason
they always examples to show stealing
April that the cell but is really long
what's that I added I added the the
three properties there because otherwise
you don't know what we're talking about
if they just put atomic mass of the
element an atomic mass of the isotope
then what are we talking about like just
numbers it's just okay okay fair enough
and I think period one is kind of an
interesting result okay it's kind of
interesting okay this I admit this at
trial output has gotten interesting
um
okay then on our live stream is
questioning whether what we did here was
correct
okay
isn't left keep all a I and only BJ
matching the condition
you
so okay so the way I slightly disagree
with what Ben wrote because the point is
that if the condition for outer if the
condition is false you're gonna have all
the I joined with unmatched and all the
B I joined with a matched so you get the
cardinality of a plus B in outer don't
we have to describe what thing is filled
in when they don't match or it's just
not there I mean in that case no so
basically they're the canonical name is
gonna be missing unmatched and then all
the properties are gonna be missing not
applicable in the case of databases
because they lazy said we should try
that am should try that okay
I mean it's a little bit ugly because in
the built in entities we can say missing
a matched even on the properties but
databases don't have different types of
missiles they only have now so we have
to say no we have to put this line here
when a corresponding value when a
corresponding property is absent
no value is absent correct value of the
property
you
you
same in the last you said usage line
where we could say property value as
opposed to property
which one this one here missing property
values well actually this is probably
not descriptive enough we should explain
that missing will be used for all
property values for the cases when there
is no match
you
you
so if we keep for example a I and then
you know use a trace but I think we
should say to be included and we pick up
generated am i right yes
so what are you saying down yeah so a
little it is correct I'll say here
correct it is correct but it might
benefit from a bit more being said here
so like and particularly for the outer
because for the outer while we keep all
a I and BJ's the cardinality is not
generally as some
so um it might be a different
explanation that is easier
so the basic operation is inner vial on
the left one you have inner plus
something else
right one his inner plus something else
and the outer is inner plus the
additional ones for left plus additional
ones for right here and it's so more
important because if the condition is
formulated in such a way that there are
for example for a single a I there is
more than one BJ that is meeting the
condition then Cartesian products are
formed there so it means that you are
kind of exploding these pairs
so maybe somewhere we should write that
semantically unless we already wrote it
somewhere that semantically it's the
same as outer of the two things and then
select of condition applied to outer
sounds like that's a good thing to have
in properties in relations yeah because
I just want to know is this correct is
it correct that if you say left then you
keep all of the a sub I yeah it is
correct but it may give an impression
that you will have the cardinality equal
to the cardinality of the set a which is
not what that depends on the B because
if you have matches for single a with
multiple B is then you have more things
than just a list of a sum A's will be
repeated several times
so if you have a one that matches b1 b2
and b3 then a1 will be repeated three
times in the result and maybe what we
said over here enjoying across is the
better way to say it which was well read
it
allow the AI for which there is no
matching bi yeah I think it's not bad
yeah
you
okay
good all right let's move on look next
aggregate identity class or extended
easier
I think extended was mostly done okay
so this very famous last words
it was done because I had with in this
yours when you removed it so
so why didn't we note that it was done
no idea
you
you
see I remember writing this desk we did
this
okay last but not least aggregated
entity class which I believe we've not
tackled that correct yeah we I think we
briefly looked into it but then switch
to the combined energy class okay
represented ventricles containing a
single entity with the property prop
whose value is the result of applying
the function to class
the function to
to the list of elements in class that
right
some cases for a law for example
database back-end it's really not
applied to a list
well conceptually it to the left
conceptually yes conceptualize to the
transposed Association but it's really
the reason why we had said class
directly it because auntie value already
has the correct behavior so if you
really are applying them I mean it's
applied to the to the class in that
sense
okay representatives cake last the
result of applying the function asked
so I want to make it clear that it's
it's like a total or something like that
it's not yeah like gulp the whole thing
in
actually it's to the property values of
the entities of class
mmm is it I don't think so I think it's
just a function no because - what an
example
scroll down okay wait a minute with the
properties the result of applying a
function f2
you
okay but this is the case where
apply enough to the value
value of all properties
of the property prop
no no no no wait wait wait to you if you
write that you're gonna paint yourself
into a corner as if you're what is it
which property is it is it computing no
look at the first detail look at the
first detail that usage message
encompasses two thing one is the full
entity function which might contain more
than one prop so you might be doing you
know like some weird competition
dividing the total something by the mean
of something else okay okay fine today
after the
you
to the hole specified class I think that
is fine and we should keep it a bit
vague otherwise we have to make three
more use advantages ok construct
multiple properties obtained by applying
each of the I'm
okay
okay containing as many entities are as
there are distinct values
okay well let's first of all say
what the heck is this
I see
but how how does that function get
applied Oh maybe it's worth saying that
it's applied to the groups grouped by
the property grouping alright
sorry I'm just got distracted by
something okay okay say this again I
think it's worth saying that the way it
is computed computing things is by
applying a function to the property to
the grouped grouped entities so it
creates groups IP IP okay okay represent
the cars containing
that's nonsense there
that's absolutely nonsense but what is
grouping a property
private property or there is not a
religious message for list of properties
okay
many entities with distinct values of
the property grouping
this is correct but it doesn't explain
the mechanics of how things are done
okay
whether that represents a class
okay
okay when we say groups
you
you
um
groups the elements of class
according to their values
the property
call it tree proper I think you wanna
see the values of their values of the
oops the elements of class according to
no no their values
of the property tree prop
um then generates
an entity class
- wearing an entity for
each of these groups
but right yeah I mean I still think that
you can't save there and then of thee
but I'm not nice figure okay with their
book genitive but yeah but still I never
liked genitive only in Latin which is
perhaps related to Italian I don't know
so if you have group here than also
change grouping to group in the in no no
no I know this has to be changed okay
I'm saying three prop
okay
okay groups the elements of class
according to their values
you
the property cheap prop then generates
an entity class
with an entity
okay why don't we say forms groups of
elements
of cloth
and generates an entity class with an
entity for each of these groups I think
that's okay that makes sense
you
you
okay so now what is this one
this says
you
okay well
groups forms groups
for which
all the values of properties cheaper by
are distinct
that's correct yes
you
except it might sound if you formulated
this way it might sound as if you are
comparing prop 1 to prop 2 etc okay
which all the values of properties 3
power for each entity
I would just say whether were the
combination of value is G prop 1 etc are
distinct
you
the set of values
but properties that reasonable yeah okay
this sets them of values apprenticed the
sets
multi-floral formed group for which the
sets of now is no it can be singular
that which the group then is distinct
either the set square yes yes yes yes
you're right
yep you're right okay
okay what is this one
you
okay let's do this whoops that's doing
you
this may have to be fixed
I'm the sick stuff okay
okay now this one forms groups
according to the values tiny left the s
but but where where wait wait wait wait
wait okay yes
sorry hold on obtained
by applying the entity functions
buh-bye actually that is not the main
point of the last message I think using
anti D functions very we can use that
property is implicit already known the
key point of that last message is that
you can introduce the name property or
an alias to later use it but I don't
think that in this case we allow we are
loved with the naked property because
that means that the canonical name
doesn't doesn't have a name the truth or
we can say as a sub cases that you can
rename these properties that you want to
and also shouldn't the last one be the
second-last just as one and then you
have a list of group specs
yeah I agree with that
you
but I don't think this is what
tournament oh yes a curious oh you meant
this player he okay bones groups
according to the values obtained by
applying the entity function ask
with the resulting properties given
you
you
Oh God
forms groups according to values value
values obtained by applying the entity
function f
with the resulting property named P name
but correct yes
okay he knows it but that string
teammate I know but we usually do it
this way um okay so now here we say we
so if we usually do it this way then
that's gonna use a message is wrong
you
okay of values defined by the P spec I
okay I think I have to disappear fairly
soon here um okay hold on
the single entities were met but they're
not the single entities in the first
argument there are no single entities
the class in the first argument yeah but
the point is that the point is that the
second argument of aggregate identity
class does not automatically friend the
third argument does okay okay so I
applied to the individual entities
you
applied separately to the individual
entities
I hate saying first argument second
argument you know what I'm going to redo
this
in aggregated entity class of class
comma prop spec comma what are we going
to call the other the final thing cheese
spec
by the way this should be G spec one
respect too
okay um and props back
you
Enclave next dress
it's props boobs back on the first one
has nice rest
entity function expressions in props
back are are applied to the entity class
class as an entity class
that's not entirely correct because
usually if you take an entity function
in your plate to an entity class it will
thread okay so look what we want to do
is give the two argument case here first
and then give the three argument case
because there's no grouping there's a
case without grouping right actually we
could handle the three a common case
first and then say the tortilla min case
there's just one group no we say
normally we have various groups and into
argument case it's one okay prop spec
are applied to the entity classes
obtained from class by using the
grouping specification cheese spec okay
about this okay tell me what actually
true this entity function get applied to
an entity class or to something
different so when you apply an entity
function 20 class outside of this
context it will auto thread on all the
single entities inside the entity class
okay so this is a very special behavior
that if I were pointing it out and also
also there is another difference that
the groups that are being formed they
are at best virtual entity classes we
can never single them out they are only
interline why couldn't you have an I
mean okay we don't actually get fed to
this thing what I mean if I have a
function if this is the top-level code
and I'm not doing it through some weird
external database what happens if I have
the function okay if you have no thanks
okay if this was top-level code then
this would actually so and if you
imagine that entities are a class of
entities is a list of associations then
you would feed that function the the
transposition of these two associations
so that would actually read or not in
I mean in SQL who knows what it does
what is it actually fed yeah Tony should
answer well I did what a database group
told me but I some day ago I had or some
days a long time ago I had proposed and
I could gate or an entity aggregate
function because it's so different and
in for instance Barco and other
languages there listen it's a big
difference between aggregate all my
functions I mean it's it's a thematic we
have to be clear when you say entity
function right here and I'm gonna have
to go and unfortunately we're gonna have
to schedule yet another meeting here
um but yeah just a minute just a minute
when you say enter the function here I
have got an entity function it's got an
X and it's going to do things here what
does that X bind to so effectively you
have entity value of x comma properties
so wherever you find X of something you
transform it to entity value of x comma
property
okay hold on in this case here so in
this case I came up with some kind of
explanation that justifies it somewhat
and the idea is that you introduce new
virtual entities you can imagine however
you want to do it like by registering a
store or you know that has those are of
a different type and whose property
values are list valued they have the
same names but their list values of the
list valued by no no Steven Steven
Steven Steven let's backtrack for a
second Tony is right that they don't
have the same application semantics but
in general if you're mapping or applying
a function the function is still
function you don't change the wrapper
that is basically just holding the code
now because you're applying it in a
different way that's but what does it
mean in that case what is it okay okay
so in the first in this case it means
it's bits instead of being a list of
Association its association with list
values this is what it means so
basically you will have in this case by
the way we should have a better way to
get rid of the missing here absolutely
okay so if I put up here let's do a
simple thing let's say g8
okay I mean by the way that really seems
like an example that's worth giving
yeah Berkeley but we all should also
mention them that for databases the set
of functions you can apply your
restricted yes
we polish it said in a bunch of other
places as well but this for me is that
is clarifying that's what it's doing
mm-hmm okay so I think we should say are
in effect
applied to the list
well I'm going to get rid of this one
are in effect
artifact applied to the
list of values
of properties
you
um a properties in class
you
and then we have a similar thing here
you
well I would say lists not necessarily
list why because you can have for
example a of population multiplied by e
of population again or of a of something
else but the question is what is e as
well as what is e
ar e is an association with the keys
being the same property isn't nothing we
have to stay here that's what we have to
say because what we're going to be
saying is what is the e well welcome to
England yes but one can think of E as an
association with the keys being the same
properties population is either etc and
very fine fine fine art effect applied
to a list
you
of associations no no no turn
association of lists
you
I see to an association of lists of
values least valued maybe
no it's list two values yeah yeah was
the keys being the same properties by
tunis to an association
um
you
whose values are the lists of values
for the entities in class pretty
convoluted
you
what do we say for the third argument of
group by
listen I really have to go guys um
uh we got a schedule another one of
these unfortunately um so there it is
hopefully soon
um right okay we go back next time
please please make sure that you guys
are really on top of what has to be done
and that you really know what still left
to be done what has been looked at what
hasn't been looked at yeah okay yeah
okay you guys doing so nice team bye-bye